what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
so today we are starting off hot with
the Logan Paul and Dylan Dennis stories
for those of you that haven't been
following the story Dylan and Logan are
scheduled to fight next month coming up
to this fight
um Dylan has taken it upon himself to
really dig through Logan's fiance's past
so Logan is engaged to Nina agdalis and
she is a supermodel and she's been in
the scene for a decade and really has
made quite the name and reputation for
herself Dylan has posted her with over
50 men over 50 different men uh we don't
know exactly who she dated and who she
did it but a lot of the images that have
been shared have been quite sexual um in
nature Logan really has been saying no
no these are long-term relationships and
they're trying to make it into something
else but Dylan on the other hand says no
no no you're trying to silence me and
you are basically living in delusion
your girl is a 304.
um so you know they've really been going
back and forth
um and you know she's been pictured with
celebrities like LeBron James
Bow Wow
um you know a Leonardo DiCaprio
so I mean this chick has been she knows
a lot of famous people I'll say that so
Dylan danis had a couple tweets today he
said they're attempting to silence me
Elon is one of Nina's former partners oh
Elon Musk
she didn't just make it into Hollywood
she made it into the billionaire
Community you know what'd be interesting
I bet Nina as I was thinking I was like
if Nina wanted to make money off this
I I would just do a how-to book how do
you get in the room I mean obviously you
have to be super hot but like there's a
lot of hot chicks that cannot get into
the same room as these guys
I'm like if I was Nina my your
reputation's already ruined you might as
well write a book like um Brittany
Renner did
I mean the chick at least made some
money off a book I mean
so this is just how I think okay I have
some epic stuff for you all ha ha can't
wait for you to see I'm nowhere near
running out of ammo I want to cook
unshadow band me Elon Musk now
uh he's getting four million views on
these tweets is this is this Shadow band
Dylan danis pulled over 2 billion views
on Twitter in the last 28 days Dylan
please I want to see your ex pay out
play I'm like well how much money did
this man make
okay so now he's got a picture of her
between a guy's legs
oh they really
um okay so now we got Dylan tweeting him
saving Logan Paul okay okay now and now
I guess another video of Nina's come out
with a different guy
[Music]
oh dear
Nina why would why would that be a good
idea
why would okay
I mean this is just showing a lack of
Shame
we really need to bring back shame in
this Society because this is just
getting ridiculous this is going to be a
wife and mother someday
and you know it'd be really and I'd like
to hear her point of view I'll I'll
invite her on I'm a nice chick I'll let
you explain all of this
um but it's really showing we're just in
a cloud economy like people will do damn
near anything for clout
so on Twitter Dylan has really been
speaking about how he has a nuke he says
a nuke picture that will absolutely ruin
the fight he says if he posts this
picture the fight will be canceled you
know Logan and him have been going back
and forth Logan says he's a liar
um and all of this is alive
but there's a video that's come out of
him showing Aiden the video so let's go
can I ask you a question like oh no no
no no I know why can I say that no like
who I don't know
guys this is heating up I mean guys this
is why women were supposed to be virgins
on our wedding day because there's a lot
of men where there's no evidence of this
and they might not know it because it
was before the social media age but a
lot of guys have wifed up chicks like
just like this
um and so this is why I really think we
gotta bring virginity back we're all the
chat all the men will only give marriage
to the women that are virgins